a días de la visita del papa- francisco
los habitantes de caracas continúan las
labores de reconstrucción de su ciudad
buena parte fue destruida durante la
ocupación yihadista entre 2014 y 2016
30h está manejada a dos combatientes de
edades se utilizaron esta iglesia para
instrucción militar y según 'the three
batas quería después de cuatro años del
fin de los combates sólo la mitad de la
población ha regresado este cura espera
que el papá anime a los demás a que
hagan lo mismo después de la liberación
de la ciudad la iglesia motivó a sus
habitantes para que regresaran a
reconstruir sus casas algunos lo
hicieron pero con prudencia pues cuando
les atacó la ciudad fue destruida la
aihs de asia a partir de 2003 caracas
creció y se expandió muchos de los
cristianos perseguidos del país llegaron
a esta ciudad casi ciento por ciento
cristiana donde había oportunidades de
empleo una época que evocan con algo de
nostalgia
me ganaba la vida trabajando como obrero
había trabajo y cuando en mi pueblo no
había empleo le iba a buscar a erbil
pero hoy la situación en caracollo está
muy difícil no hay trabajo y la vida
diaria se volvió difícil y más allá de
alguna distribución de alimentos por
parte de asociaciones a los habitantes
se quejan de la falta de apoyo de las
autoridades algunas familias han
prosperado gracias a la ayuda de ongs
hacer caso de issam quien dirige un
granero manu desplazaron dejamos todo lo
que teníamos y cuando regresamos no
teníamos nada no había dinero
afortunadamente llegó una ong que nos
ayudó a poder respirar de nuevo su
granero fue financiado por la asociación
francesa fraternidad en irak según sus
representantes volviendo a tejer el lazo
económico se reconstruye confianza la
idea es que la ciudad vuelva a vivir que
toda la región vuelva a vivir la
economía comienza a repuntar lo que
permite volver a crear lazos entre las
personas entre las comunidades y así
reconstruir la paz social ante un
llamado a la coexistencia punto central
del mensaje que el papá transmitirá a lo
largo de
visita a irak